président mal élu après une
invraisemblable série de décomptes de
voix george walker bush s'est finalement
conquis le coeur des américains depuis
le 11 septembre ses hésitations ses
cafouillages sont désormais oubliés il
passait pour maladroit et se révèle
aujourd'hui extraordinairement populaire
alain de chalvron et aaron dimon
lorsque d'orge de beaulieu bouche prête
serment en janvier dernier il est le
plus mal élu dé président américain est
en fait il a même été choisi par la cour
suprême et les américains se demandent
avec un peu d'angoissé en le voyant
ainsi dansé le jour de sa prestation de
serment
si la cour a fait le bon choix
il y avait beaucoup de points
d'interrogation sur ses capacités il
n'avait jamais eu une pause nationaux et
même d'une certaine manière sur son
intelligence tellement il avait fait de
gaffes durant la campagne
ainsi bush avait t-il du avoué ne pas
connaître le nom du président du
pakistan un de ses principaux
interlocuteurs quelques mois plus tard
bush calandra il travaille délègue
beaucoup
et fait le tour du pays on a parfois
l'impression qu'il est plus à l'aise sur
les terrains de sport
que dans son bureau
arrive le 11 septembre
george bush est alors en floride dans
une école pris de court comme tout le
monde cornwall fromage
il paraît décontenancé pour des raisons
de sécurité il passera le plus clair de
son temps ce jour là à tourner en avion
et l'amérique à un moment l'impression
qu'il n'y a pas de pilote aux commandes
de retour à la maison blanche
il paraît au bord des larmes
dans les jours qui suivent des banlieues
fait un sans faute d'une visite à
manhattan sur les lieux de l'attentât où
il trouve les mots justes
et un discours historique devant les
deux chambres du congrès
justice sera faite
bush se transforme en chef de guerre
liquide en quelques semaines le régime
des talibans ce qui n'était pas gagné
d'avancé
et même si le sort de ben laden est
encore incertain sa popularité frise les
80 % je pense que le contenu a été très
bien gérée avec bush et ses faucons
aujourd'hui on aurait pu s'attendre mais
on aurait pu craindre une réaction
des frappes aveugles de beaucoup de
forces militaires un peu partout sans
vraiment réfléchir à une stratégie
bush le héros peut aujourd'hui prendre
des vacances dans son ranch du texas
sans que personne ne le soupçonne de ne
pas aimer son travail